okay for those joining this livestream
we are talking about the wolfram
function repository which is something
which kind of doesn't exist yet but will
soon but kind of does exist um and let's
take a look here it's test function
repository is that the right place to be
looking or is it not the test server
none of this is web stuff it's all
notebook based okay all right okay so I
need to install the splat let I need to
basically run this cell correct yes in
desktop in desktop yeah you might want
to download that
well I don't need to I just go ahead and
run this sure okay now what am I looking
at here so this is we put in a lot of
sort of style changes to like the
messages and warnings button styles
since last time and we also wanted to
review the content of those which is the
things further down on the agenda for
reviewing the content but if you just if
you want one of these that you can
actually use to poke around that's why
you needed the back let it stop I say
okay well so should I look at this so
should I just look at the content stuff
I think okay let's just let's just do a
little tour of the of the thing here so
open sample okay how much of the I mean
that it will be useful in the sample to
maybe show some things with subscripts
and superscripts here yeah we can look
now we have a lot more things to choose
from we can choose them more complex no
so this isn't him right this thing here
that's in the wrong font
that's not the right form pearl correct
right I should is it not showing up it's
like sorry sorry tell resume well no no
it's the wrong font it's a text font it
shouldn't be a text font for some reason
right it's not the same as that font
there and should be right yep no but you
understand right it's wrong and I
understand how it managed to be wrong
getting that it's an inline cell I want
my pinky and cell should have correctly
formatted as code right I think it
should be the same as up to this within
it that's because up to is a system
function and position lightest is not
right should be linked which we assume
font I see okay now if this is
sample why doesn't it have everything in
it yeah I think I said we could probably
go through and find one that's more
complete now it's a good idea this was
like this a thing we put in and it was
good at the time okay now that we have
hundreds to choose from we can choose a
better one we could also do a sample
that is all of the elements instead of
an exact sample of an existing I think
that would be a bad idea yeah I agree
with that
a Franken sample yes I think that's a
good idea I think it's a good idea
because otherwise people will think that
yeah yeah we can do that well I think we
want them to at least belong together so
somebody could hit preview or deploy
whatever just to see how that stuff all
right okay I retract my Franken's ISM
try and find a reasonable you know
uniform example and I don't see any
reason why I mean but what would happen
if they submitted it we just reject it
hey yeah Kevin here okay I think if they
just
I can find and replace on the name and
change it to position largest - it would
probably work but then we would reject
it when we reviewed okay what is this
and why is it and this this seems to
have an ID for a minute it is an iframe
once embedded notebooks is on production
we are going to use this I'll use that
technology here so which is Wednesday
right I'm not going to make promises for
cloud releases well it's supposed to
mean once assuming it is Wednesday then
you guys will quickly you know get the
stun so that it's ready when we have to
announce it yeah yeah we didn't care too
much about formatting at this point
because we knew that we wanted to use
that technology for this what does this
mean why is that true well we don't want
so we don't want the code in a
functionary source to be doing get of a
user's cloud object they might know we
don't but but they could do I mean they
can get things from our repositories we
should say that that there's no problem
with it getting stuff from repositories
because somebody may need code or know
on that or something like this I think
we should be clear that it can't get it
from an external resource that is not a
standard Wolfram repository yeah what
I'm saying unless it's specifically
designed to connect to some service like
I was say that yeah but that's that
would be like retrieving content not
retrieving the function definition yeah
no external code sources
yeah but we should have an exception
there for either function repository
itself or you know other repositories
right this you should explain reword
that you should explain that a little
bit more yep and this for goodness sake
make those links so people know what to
do here
like I said the Friday yes this this is
wrong
that just you know this needs to be a
link to that menu item documentation
right I think we were are planning to
sort of reform at everything here once
we're doing the embed notebooks you know
there's just to get some sort of common
content up there that's makes good sense
all right okay but this particular thing
um we should explain and I think Roger
has that what is in a scope section well
why doesn't this have other sections
here when it builds because this is a
sample where nobody the person didn't
put anything in scope if they put
something in it would be there no I mean
in other other stuff but I mean okay
if you look in the uncompleted one okay
so listen
listen we need for every one of those
sections we need a description which I
believe Roger has right look at that
in the I button next to examples right
there there's at least one liner that's
previous okay that seems sensible right
we could copy that over into the style
guidelines notebook as well I think we
should also um
let's see yeah I mean we should probably
also have eyes next to each of these
sections and maybe amplify a little bit
yeah right now we're not we don't have
anything technically preventing people
from just using their own subsection
headings but we don't want that we don't
want that we subject them on review oh
sure yeah we should reject them
immediately the pre-flight should only
allow these we should also make it clear
you don't have to fill in something look
the number one thing we should make
clear is that people should make this
look like the way it works for system
functions and another thing is not every
one of these sections other than basic
examples has to be there right right so
we should say most basic function usage
paren required we also should make it
very clear what is this what is this
nonsense insert page break no that's not
correct
yeah that's not correct okay please yeah
right before we add it to tools toolbar
okay well so got that right um okay
you're gonna we're gonna do a Content
review in a few minutes then I think but
but I'm just looking through here so
tools why have that double borders
around this thing see that see the
little extra border e things I'm not
sure about that I only see that on Mac
and I I'm not sure it's cousin that okay
okay
I think the
a little bit light looking I mean
they're okay it's okay it's alright okay
okay that's all good okay okay there's a
question from Sandra on the live stream
his function in shuffle can be found
using so are we doing the autocompletes
now so we doing yes that's nice right if
I take yeah they're only updated at
kernel restart so but I think that's
fine that's just fine yeah um so Sanda
says is in shuffle I'm not seeing his in
shuffle here on kernel restart you said
yes is that left over from the creation
if he had created register to copy
that's true he might have it he might
have it from when he created it
registering a pen so so so that so he
might have it locally but it's not
actually globally deployed right could
be yeah we also we did we did approve in
shuffle but we didn't fully publish it
because of some graphics issues on the
stomach sense yeah if they're well did
we get back to sander yeah what's that
process for that we're supposed to have
a process the process is we
provisionally approve because we are
fine with the function and we fix it
soon enough
to what do we get right because they're
gonna get confused if that thing is not
showing up right I'm not sad I'm
guessing that sander just checked and
found that it existed yeah all right now
the code exists but the web page isn't
existing a public forum I think this was
on Friday afternoon yeah we just haven't
gone
if fixed but the main point is that
sounded in here from you guys right well
he would have sorry as soon as we fixed
the web page rendering and make the web
page public it would send out
notification no I understand that but
but okay so are you saying when we
provisionally approved something we
should also get back to them absolutely
of course and tell them why it isn't
fully approved if it's if it's something
that's that they need to do of course we
do that but this was doesn't matter
doesn't matter doesn't matter we got a
show that we're actually doing something
and it didn't just fall off the edge of
the earth well that's the here's the
thing as far as Saunders knows the real
problem is just that that he somehow
discovered it through this code
completion mechanism I don't care he
would just assume it's still on the
queue I mean from his point of view it
is but the more we can say that
something happened the better off we are
true this is a situation where we didn't
just to correct assertion well we didn't
provisionally approve it because we only
discovered the shingle issue after we
approved it so maybe there's oh well
that's a different that's even yet
another thing because he probably got a
notice saying it was approved in that
yeah exactly so that might be so did
that happen or did that not happen I
don't think unless you notice you go out
when it's actually published yes yes you
know make a comment the more stuff we
send out telling people what's happening
to people's submissions the better it is
so if we approved it but it isn't yet
published for some reason we say it's
approved it will be published shortly
right just transparency okay
and if something goes wrong then you
know then we got multiple eyes watching
it so the author will also notice if we
said oh it's gonna go out shortly and
then it doesn't then they'll complain
and that's good yeah that's true
okay um cool I have to read the
documentation to know what this does
let's see it does that actually like a
deck of cards okay think about it takes
the first half in the second half in so
that that page won't to exist yet
that's the 404 page that's another
problem
right what is this it's a long-standing
issue it's for a for Bradley do you know
more about the status if making that
work it's cuz we run the resources
subdomain so it's trying to grab clout
for a four page yeah there's there's two
issues there we are not able to deploy
our own 404 page so we've been waiting
for that to be fixed but also the lack
of styling is a separate issue we might
be able to fix the lack of styling soon
but we definitely need cloud investment
to fix the water on fluorophore why do
we need I mean it wouldn't be terrible
to have a am okay that worked right if
you open up the details it's not the
right title foot to use the for this I
think it's good to be - instead of
friends there's also an example that
we're trying to distinction from and the
definition that we're trying to
distinguish it from why don't we say I
mean what what does it say when you that
we don't want to say Wolfram function
repository documentation maybe not
well there is documentation for the
wolfram function repository so we might
want to not reuse the specific term
right okay
um so the specific thing that this
tripped up on is in the details and
options there's images that weren't
formatted in a way we anticipated and so
we have to get that working on the web
side of things and then I will be it's
good to let people put in images for
these things yeah yeah yeah and we
support we've added support for our
images I think I don't know some some
box
it's a graphics object this this looks
like a weird piece of formatting as well
oh yeah that's not that shouldn't be
well yeah but what is that table is that
is that a sub items I guess that's not
do we allow sub item Oh should we turn
it into a one column table that's not
what sander actually submitted though he
he or she I think it's a he had
submitted like a regular item so and
then I think a couple of text cells
below it but when it got scraped it got
turned into a sub item for some reason
okay well okay look we have a very
standardized format this is clearly not
completely conforming right figure out
what we're going how we're going to
extend it and we need to bounce back
things that don't configure our auto
formatting tools are very very much been
centered on making the webpages and then
giving after they're processed well if
the web pages look fine I'm I'm probably
okay but the whole point is we don't
have items and sub-items in you know in
sort of our documentation structure
they're just not a thing that we we
support so we have to decide what to
turn them into so that they're
consistent with other stuff and
documentation they could turn into a one
column table perfectly well right and I
think
I said for when we're making it so that
they are handled well on the website of
things I understand that but I'm gonna
say this again okay we need to make sure
that the format here is consistent with
the format that we use for all
documentation so no weird extra cell
types let they've let me mapped into
something that we already understand
yeah that's an ongoing project we're
gonna be making those sorts of changes
for a while I think fair enough
these are nice diagrams maybe there
should be a diagram make a victim maybe
there should be something that allows
you to spec a diagram like this that
would be cool um okay
all right now um let's see where were we
we were looking at we were back over
here and we were going to go to your
agenda again alright so the first one
we've pulled out a few common errors or
warnings what what does the
administration side of this now look
like okay yeah there's a lot of pieces
that's the same peclet install thing
that second blob you can delete your
very done that okay okay fine okay
question um let's just talk about
processors um for that so you have an
internal management interface yes yes is
it in notebooks yes okay and that
involves internal comments and things
ones that get sent to other people Tom
we'll be debuting shortly the commenting
in notebook correspondence tools are
yeah the one main piece of it isn't
testing the other main piece will be
testing what's the first one is
through that make sense okay now want
one of question with these things
presumably we are eventually intending
these to also be usable in private
clouds this tool Fred sure yep so we
will presumably have how will we be
deploying that is is that tool set its
itself a function repository set of
tools or what is it how does it what
what does it um it's a pathway I okay
when we have a pass that repository it
could be a packet in there it's not when
we have the pressure I mean how do we
expect to deploy this so then people
would load that in and then they have a
whole world of having an administration
interface is that correct right I mean
then additionally there's the step of
actually deploying a resource system
into their private cloud which go could
be I mean the same back lid or a
different back lift right I mean I think
the other thing that we are you know we
should think about at some point is
community based resource systems and you
know I just don't know it depends on the
evolution of all of this and whether
they're end up being specialized pieces
and so on but I think it's something
that we should anticipate could could
make sense with a good flow control
maybe no I'm thinking I'm thinking like
the the Stack Exchange folk could run
one of these or our um you know that
type of things um I don't know whether
it's a good idea because I mean it you
know hopefully our one works well enough
that people will just use it um but
there may be specialized pieces that
we're not going to cover very well I
mean it may be that I I don't know I
don't know um
or it could I could imagine a
specialized one where somebody wants to
build one of these but it is
specifically for functions to generate
homework or something
right um and they're going to curate it
and it's going to be you know hundreds
and hundreds of functions to generate
specific types of homework exercises
okay let's so go through this alright
now what do you what do you what are you
trying to show me each one of these is
just one thing that we think is a common
either warning or suggestion so this is
just to sort of review the actual
content of those warnings for some that
we selected why are we putting photos of
it now you said it out now it is so
that's our bit old yeah okay okay what's
the right-hand side I see what happened
in that case looks magnificent they add
automatically linked the the function
names I could see that that's part of
what made it magnificent um it's a
little bit of a pity that those brackets
end up being oversized I don't know why
that's happening that should probably be
looked into
okay okay what I'm saying yeah something
is confused with the hyperlinks that's
causing them to expand
um and you okay now but but there could
be things with commas in them at that
are key words but that's very rare
then you just say dismiss or you know
okay fine okay
what's the arrow going through here Oh
somebody's got a bunch of background
hissing noise um so those ones don't
have a knot effect so it's just that
don't you don't show this again or
dismiss this so that's not only gotta
fix I understand okay
what do we mean invalid link
oh I see this is this is the link
section yeah okay fine yep
you
okay
magnificent yeah are you are you dealing
with putting
Cullens at the end of lines and all that
kind of stuff yeah yes
I think that's the example after this
one
you
well don't we automatically do this for
people
why don't we just do that automatically
if they put in three dots we turn it
into the right thing
all its specifically set up so it's not
gonna automatically
rewrite things just in case it's
something they actually want so it'll
automatically do it use that option from
the menu but you know that somebody
might have a function that actually does
that and they're showing an example that
we wouldn't want to ruin there but it's
only gonna do this in the usage section
right if I remember correctly it also
check the example text okay fine fine
details and options would have this also
okay but I mean I think it should be
more insistent here and possibly should
just fixed it automatically well how
much are we fixing automatically and how
much do we insist the source page
it's it's mostly just saying it found
something and you have the option of
having a fixed automatically I
understand I would argue that in this
usage section we should escalate this to
be something that is really an orange
level alert so to speak oh oh yeah so
increase really yeah yeah cuz I think
would be extremely rare that somebody
would actually deliberately want the
three periods right okay
you
you
when would they ever not appear with a :
you
um it's a silly example but on birds say
this on the ends in a question mark but
in general I think almost always oh it's
fine I'd only this okay
yeah yeah it's all good I I think that's
a yellow alert or whatever it is all
right we had want that inconsistency
it's silly to have it there's no there's
no excuse for having it let's just force
it okay
you
as the words set right here
is this okay
I don't know maybe this is okay but but
um
that's all right
a roadie who's writing this knows okay
what does that mean
so something's undocumented but it does
exist we wouldn't build to put a link to
it on like a shingle page right but I
don't think that that
boy um
I think this is um
yeah I mean the undocumented system
symbols are just something we wanted
pretend don't exist
okay well I think we should say um
well no one would see this message and
unless they knew about the symbol and
all right
okay fine fine
you
you
um I really think this is very very very
rare to not start with a capital letter
I think I would up the celerity in this
one again okay
imagine a French proper name that's like
do something yeah yes I can imagine
stuff like that too
um I assume you've got a thing that
checks for the period at the end
it's not implemented yet but I have it
coming okay
you
okay
what's the difference between these I
understand the top line and bottom line
so this is the actual usage pattern the
second one is the sentence oh I see we
just didn't happen this is a fake
example because there isn't in fact a
first a second it sees that versus Oh
variables oh wow and this one has a
pretty high chance of having false
positives so that's one of the reasons
why we have the don't show again for
this though because alright first cuz
it'll be an adjective um hold on let's
think about this one this one is a
little trickier
you know why don't we say arguments are
not formatted in italics etc well what
do we call it at the top and they in the
eminent arguments
I'm not formatted as template input or
something a not formatted as paren
italic template input this yeah this'll
actually also identify if somebody use
italics and not template input which we
we want them to fix
you
you
um sorry say that again excuse me could
you repeat that I I was avoiding using
the word italics in this message because
like formatting has italics is wrong in
this case in this case for arguments
because I would end up with the wrong
font
you
I see
well maybe arguments are not formatted
as template input yeah I think that
makes sense okay
look you either got to state these
messages as a fact of what isn't there
the should isn't really a message um
you know are we using sugar we just
state in what's there
um arguments um strings or
I mean could we say something like um
let's see I mean are we able to put in
actual things very you know when I can
go has parameters yeah first and second
um
you
well are not
you
you
is that correct
ah yeah used in the template in the
function template argument names used in
the function template are not formatted
as template input in the description
yeah and after function template it
could be paren first time a second
closed paren well here better argument
names first time a second there's more
robust if there's one or five of them
yeah yeah okay that's what I would
suggest shall I send this to you um Rick
you have a written down also just Rick
anyway I'm okay um you see some comments
on our live stream
Santa won't ignore their fontsize rules
for the graphics that is a good question
we should give those we should mention
graphics we should probably check the
font sizes
I mean arguably those graphics have to
go through some human review
everything goes through interview fair
enough but okay let's give guidelines
for the for the font sizes right
certainly know them because we've been
doing it for our own documentation for
eons right yeah first we need to support
it as much as we can we can we can give
guidelines but we also need to improve
the actual tools so that we support more
things stander gave us we should it
should work but it's right sanga's
nicely saying that he wants to say he
really likes the idea of the function of
Huzur tree very good he's graduated ten
to fifteen functions more to come
excellent excellent
um are there rules for numbered
arguments
um oh I see that is a good question We
certainly have some style guidelines for
that
whether you say thing one thing to comma
dot dot we should mention that the next
screen shot is relevant to that as well
I think okay okay a question for
Mohammed after downloading function
repository function does it create a
local copy of its documentation I don't
know the answer to that what's the
answer it creates a local copy of the
documentation but so the documentation
notebook itself is created on demand but
it's created from local stuff but so so
right now for people to get
documentation they are taken to the web
is that correct we don't have the
canonical documentation is on the web we
have that notebook that you looked at
earlier for the site which in principle
if people want it and I'd be interested
to know if there's a use case for this
if people want it those things could
then be resident locally I mean look
like you know typical example is
somebody downloads bunch of functions
from function repository they go in a
cave they go on a plane without Wi-Fi
and they want to keep using it and use
the documentation right yeah the
retrieving the the notebook
documentation for a published function
is something that pretty much works but
it hasn't really been through testing
its undocumented we need to make it more
robust for things like those sub items
right yeah I understand but I'm asking
the following question like in our
documentation structure right now there
is no place for the function repository
in the in product function documentation
right it's layout right we might want to
review that also for the other
repositories making a good question for
to ask users because I don't see the use
case right now but maybe somebody does
yeah sort of updating indices
janna where i'm stuck we can certainly
talk so I understand that it's not
obvious how you link the thing to this
and you know how you keep things in sync
and so on but it's a question of people
think it's important then we should look
at it
let's see
yeah all right let's
go take a look here maybe needs
subscripts
you
you know I'm perfectly happy saying
should probably be I I don't think it
needs to be just a statement so I think
I started using that's her terminology
for a lot of these and I just haven't
updated all of them okay all right fine
okay now what are we recommending for
subscripts in the tools section are we
giving them literal subscripts
or are we allowing the dollar sign
notation or something you don't think
you create a subscript box just like
that you know the palate for the
templating palette but the dollar sign
if you put in the dollar sign and use
template input that works as well
maybe we should tell people that do we
tell them not underneath more info
button I'm not sure we should check that
I don't think we document it anyway we
should probably document it as a
shortcut and people who submit many of
these will learn it fine
okay
should we say avoid using new symbols
for function names since I think it'll
be somewhat obscure what Global means if
they had it in the context of their own
and they wanted to document it using
that context that will be a horrible
kind of worms
yeah yeah let's just say new symbols
yeah I think that makes no sense
why don't we just say fixed
automatically oh I think that was a copy
and paste mistake on my part okay so the
second notebook is just a dump of all of
the text from all of the more info
buttons and why doesn't selecting I
haven't a clue but anyway oh boy
Rollo's text here we could spend the
next three days going through this but I
think we've set this to DQ a as well
right yeah but that's okay we'll look at
it in just a moment here
so um okay so Santa is commenting that
in 12 that we correctly have
we take this blob
okay so that's the right size at least
okay if we take that blob and we hover
over that blob what wait wasn't this
work why isn't that working he says to
0.10 this in 12.1 yes okay okay so there
so it gives the raft when you click it
it goes to the web documentation I see
and that could in principle go to the as
could f1 go to local documentation if we
had it right we're confident in our
local documentation we can decide
whether to switch right but I mean in
that case we would have to have a
structure somewhere on the because I'm
assuming that on the home page what's
true about that the route guide page
where does the function repository
appear in the route guide page
and shouldn't say computational notebook
archived just should just say notebook
archive
um
so in principle that could actually be
those could be internal documentation
all right okay okay let's look at um
we've been found pre building those
things so that it doesn't have a lag
yeah it's a good we can consider I'm not
sure how important it is but but it's
for the future by the way this graying
down is not real right that yeah that's
just you're on the test deployment which
has less contact so yeah it's it's real
but there's nothing that uses it on the
production line in every category has
content so you don't see it okay and by
the way you know as we get more content
we need better organization yeah yep
right probably well we probably need
guide pages that's what we probably need
and that's going to be difficult because
the guide pages require you know
balancing and knowledge and things um
more than just the listings well I think
so I mean I think we need I mean I think
they need to be put into subcategories
there yeah I mean with I don't know and
I don't know whether it's community
maintainable for example the the guide
pages
I just think this is really hard to you
know cuz you don't know what's there you
really want to be able to browse this
how many submissions we get how quickly
and you know with guide pages one of the
issues is that as you get a bunch of new
functions in a particular area you may
have to rebalance the guide page um but
that's certainly where we would like it
to be his I mean right now we have 500
functions right yes um we might be able
to you know this would take some work
and development but basically have guide
pages follow the same pattern as as
resources where someone could submit an
update and it would be reviewed so we
can put some work on our end but also
let users say hey these functions should
be added check out this idea that's a
good idea yeah it's a good idea I mean
you can we can kick that I don't like
yeah but it's a wiki except that it is
you know it has pre-emptive review I
mean the alternative would be to have
something
yeah I think it kind of has to work that
way um okay
um
you
let me see um
I'm sorry I'm just uh we're back to it
let's see I think we have another
you
yeah we have another actually livestream
meeting about geometric assertions
coming up that is at this time let me
just take a look at what else you wanted
me to look at so you want me to look at
this some I think we've we've covered
the highlights and we just also provided
a notebook with literally all over all
of the text okay so my question have you
talked to Roger about whatever
guidelines he has for um function page
writing I will check I I think we have
I'm not a hundred percent if this is
what he gave us or based on it but I'll
confirm that
yeah please do and also is it Brian
isn't here is he
you can ask him also for that right
whatever they have now is the time to
expose it I think they have some
training materials so people write in
documentation which might be highly
relevant for this um sander makes
another good point which is knitting
between functions is tricky because
changing links because they're
previously submitted functions that
might want to link to a new function
what do we do about that
I mean it's possible to submit an update
to the function and I think one of our
hopes for a future update is to make it
easier to update metadata without
changing the function and that you know
it's not fully formed at the moment but
that would be a good way to do it in
practice these relations are almost
always going to be two-way so somebody
submits a new function that says it's
related to five existing ones we could
automatically or just check real click
weather to make the opposite like well
why don't we get them to propose it the
only the only issue is it's just going
to write all the same things twice well
then why don't we do this why don't we
bring up one of these notifiers that
asks if you want to do that right on
submission if you are linking to a
pre-existing function repository
function and I don't even know how you
do that how do you do that there's a
related symbols or related functions
yeah is it obvious that that can include
a function repository function yes
that's the entire point there's there's
one called related symbols that's for
system symbols and one called related
function or related resource objects so
it could be a data resource or an ER all
that resource icy' yeah so we could I
guess we could have a checkbox that says
also create backlinks or you know okay
also submit requests with backlinks
right I mean maybe that's something we
can just do automatically anyway just
every time take a look and see if you
know any any resource that's mentioned
here you know is it the reviewers can
take a look okay there's something here
is it worth adding these backlinks okay
let me make a more concrete suggestion
okay through
I could do it or it could get sent to
the original author of the thing into
which the backlinks are being inserted
okay and I read an interesting problem
cuz it's not like you know it will be
lovely if the academic literature had
forward had forward references as well
as backward references but it does not
right in other words if you could look
at the paper and when you look at the
bottom of that paper it would say oh two
years later somebody did this
but you never have those links right but
what we're proposing is basically to
have those kinds of links so what I'm
suggesting is that what it should do is
if there is a backlink send something to
the original author saying this is the
proposed update to the links for this
function do you approve now the reason
it's tricky is that in that default it
might add the new backlinks at the end
but you might not actually want the new
backlinks at the end you get what I'm
saying maybe things like that can have
their own section and we can do that
automatically well you mean really
considering of these things but it is
important it is important yeah I'm
particularly when they start to be lots
of them right but I think that's a
reasonable thing to do to imagine a
workflow where we are sending back to
the original creator of the thing do you
approve this backlink yes no or they
don't respond in which case we have to
deal with it right we can just spin up a
web forum let's just check each one that
you agree with it's yes yeah but it
doesn't solve the O's and it does solve
they getting it in there in the first
place right all right well sounds good
so you know this needs to be ready for
the release and not too long right yep
there's there's cloud side changes that
QA hopefully is approving today or
tomorrow and there are things in this
definition notebook that are awaiting
those so this okay my insight changes
are will be going to testing as soon as
that those cloud side changes our iPhone
we've also got a couple minor changes
from the design meeting so we should
have that wrapped up and to QA very very
shortly and how soon can we move to get
this
no much better workflow in the
functional puzzle in the data repository
it's one of our next next items if we
make it top priority yeah I think we can
get it done there's one trickier ux part
when working with data that functions
that we'll have to think about well the
function has a symbol name attached to
it that you can use when you're defining
the examples and then we automatically
swap out the symbol name for I don't we
just use encoding it got dollar data or
something yeah yeah that's the solution
of now nobody likes it so I think we can
what I think we've got some patterns
that will work better when we when we
revisit it I've got some ideas based on
what we've done with function okay I
mean what do people say is wrong with
the dollar data thing I don't know maybe
if we communicated better it would work
better but it people don't understand it
the first time I've personally explained
it to you know 20 different internal
people that are so many things maybe
it's I think it's a communication
problem because I don't think this is a
fundamental problem with it I think the
people yeah I just don't think there's a
fundamental problem I think we should
just assume it works that way and try
and get a nice nicer workflow for the
whole submission independent of that
issue because I think that is a
perfectly decent solution to that issue
and I think it's just a question of just
stripping out a lot of stuff and
simplifying and putting in these
preflight notifiers just like we've done
for these alright I gotta go to this
geometric assertion meeting those who
are on the live stream if you're very
welcome to join us there we'll be
starting a couple of minutes and thanks
to everybody and talk to you all soon
thanks everyone bye